welcome to this video about tal memorial
2013 the 5th round let's get right to
the games that i start with galfond
against morris average and we get a
benoni surprisingly not benko usually
see five mins we go for a banker but
it's a regular benoni now and they are
fountain place a typical setup occupying
the center and playing h3 this is one of
the most popular lines against the
Benoni and in fact even against the
modern benoni now more was paying six
Bishop d3 and takes on d5 here white
actually has got a choice he can play
ctx d5 transposing into the modern been
only characterized them by the exchange
of VNC pawn and this is the so called
model main line with age three and
Bishop d3 align that has become popular
starting in the early 90s and nowadays
is one of the real main lines of the
Benoni hence the name model main line um
in this move order however white has
another booth and this is ETA X d5 at
first sight this looks a bit unambitious
because it only leads to a symmetrical
pawn structure and not too light having
an extra sent upon to some extent this
is true but it also means that white
still enjoys a space advantage and this
non order some the symmetrical pawn
structure means that blacks counter play
is reduced to a minimum in fact I also
always play the C txt file file
sometimes get it from the Kings Indian
move water and it takes d5 I consider to
be rather yea rather unattractive for
black it's very difficult to get some
concrete play yummers which played
rookie a Czech girl from play Bishop e3
and here in fact like a stride a number
of moves um a well-known move here as
Bishop to h6 which at first sight looks
rather good for black using this this
pin here on the e-file but white can
simply ignore or this and castle after
takes takes black cannot really afford
to take the pawn this here is far too
dangerous it's just one line with Queen
h-60 there are others but this is far
too dangerous you cannot really win the
pawn you can continue in this in this
fashion and like it's significantly yeah
maybe not significantly but black is ver
SI and needs to defend the problem is
it's nice that you seem to control a 5
with with this kind of maneuver but
white has big pressure on their father
there's also those weaknesses this
position would be entirely different if
like could play g62 g7 but okay this is
not possible so moral didn't play Bishop
h6 you can play all kinds of slow moves
but then white castles and get out of
the e-file what he did actually is this
one sacrificing an exchange and this is
no one I mean set has been played before
but it doesn't really enjoy a good
reputation the idea is that black by
giving up the rook against the dark
squared bishop that black is very strong
on the dark squares and this is true d 5
is a good square for
for a night like this or some ideas like
this are the possible then the dark
squares are really a problem for white
but it's an exchange and I really have
my doubts about that it always enjoyed a
really bad reputation to sacrifice and
in fact if you look at the game girl
phone just castled yeah now taking on e3
is really not not helping because
opening up lines for the wroxham is
really quite the opposite doesn't bring
any benefits to blacky developed space
and Queen d2 and the problem here is
that why it has a very simple plan and
this is just piling up on the FR look F
to rook af1 and how does this black get
anything here I mean it's still an
exchange um morals which was playing
rather quickly and I'm not quite sure if
he um yeah only speculation now if he
had prepared something here and it
wasn't really working out at the bought
it what maybe it's just yeah he's um a
strange player sometimes losing interest
a bit to what what's happening similar
to even shock and maybe he is I don't
know somewhat frustrated by the earlier
results on or the way the games went I
mean what I'm getting at is this getting
to this position after move 13 is really
a bit a bit strange because white is
clearly better 95mm is also not helping
this exchange but it's really easy why
just pass up on the FR see what is
blacks supposed to do if you remove the
the the night away somewhere don't know
we're here just stroke f7 so it's um
it's really really bad now like actually
played Queenie seven to allow the
capture
cause at the end you can take III and
we'll get this pawn but the issue is why
just em wins d6 while attacking at this
Bishop and c5 so white has some giving
back return the exchange but 1 upon as
some compensation and its really nice
now this extra-deep on with D 695 then
the night is also going to be very
strong piece this Bishop is not doing
much so why does essentially winning
here and it's um it took took a bit of
time but and also there was the odd
improvement for white to to win quicker
but he never really let it slip that
white no two points up yeah yeah this
was some final stroke in this game black
should try to defend against rook
air-five which he failed to do but it
really didn't matter much rook air-five
and he said now the deep on is the issue
after Luke move this check and queen d 6
and this is just just deadly threatens
to to take on fh with mate so the Queen
cannot move and after a capture what is
promoting the pole it's no way to stop
it if black blocks it and there's this
coming end up like just loses in a very
very simple manner um yeah one of those
games where you really don't know what
the black player will sir was getting at
I know maybe it's really having some
psychological issues or something and I
don't know just speculation because this
is really weird it's well known that
this is not enough and especially
against gal fought was an excellent
defender this is a really weird choice
so on the other hand while this
tournament is some turning into
um yeah something rather bad from Rosa
which galfond is in excellent shape he's
on plus 2 now and he's right in the lead
so Nakamura was on plus 2 also before
this round and known girlfriend is 0
plus 2 playing an excellent tournament
he sometimes really gets gets too little
recognition for what he's doing I think
if you I know maybe you see it
differently if you're somewhat older
let's say I'm approaching 14 myself so
seeing someone with in his mid-forties
playing the best chest of his career is
really something that that as he was
some mom yeah I like to see it just
gives you some hope that you can do good
things still yourself even if you are
slightly a slightly older alright so
let's um go through the next game and go
directly to the cameras game you played
the Russian champion and Drake in there
they have certainly a long history of
blitz matches on the internet and also
in real life but also here on a sec I
even covered a couple of them my channel
so i'm making dinner plays all kinds of
openings difficult to prepare anything i
guess and nechama replace the petrossian
variation with 83 this is designed to
prevent Bishop before of course so
White's ideas to go 93 and then occupy
the center what usually does not bein
cheto if he intends to do that it
usually does that right away a three
signals okay I'm going to play in the
Indus
with my pawns we should be seven and now
Nakamura Bishop f4 and to be honest I
never saw this move before it's really
rare it's not a novelty but it's really
rare the normal continuation he is 93 as
mentioned to prepare this d5 move and
here black has various replies to the
main one being d 5 22 stop d 45 mile
wide and get some foothold in the center
this Bishop f4 move however is certainly
not bad i mean it develops a piece and
white will continue in this in this way
and you could ask why play a three and
then Bishop f4 why not Bishop for
yourself and yourself at first and you
can do that so it's a viable line the
one problem is that after um Bishop
before check I think um it's a bit a bit
awkward for for for white play this move
then the pieces are somewhat somewhat
cluttered white normally play some night
f.2d to him and doesn't really have
doesn't really reach much I think
actually I a screwed up the move order
it sits like this and now this check now
night BD 287 it can be answered with
this amongst others yeah what I'm
getting at a 3s is sort of useful for
this setup preventing we should be four
but unbreaking goes completely different
direction place d6 not quite sure if I
would have thought about this move but
the way is playing it it makes perfect
sense actually d6 93-97 so he's
developing and he's preparing sis 75 at
the right moment but depending on
what what what is doing if you consider
for instance white playing III then
black has this idea yeah this Bishop
doesn't have any good other square and
I'll be should be seven and exchanged
and this is a quite comfortable for
black if you get rid of one pair of
bishops then um yo you don't have any
big problems Black has various ideas
with c5e 5 f-5 so you can put something
in the center later and what Paul you
use for this you can choose according to
circumstances so you three is avoided
and I can we replace Quincy to which
means that after this move white could
also just retreat and maybe even play G
for next so I'm Quincy to wear has a
point it's direct against nine h5 and
now on wrecking the place c5 so it's all
very logical Quincy to left the D file
so c5 now is an interesting move because
d5 is met by this winning a pawn it's
not entirely clear if you know the
Queen's Indian a bit you know that those
kind of sacrifices are sometimes an idea
but it is a pawn so like can could take
that and this means why it doesn't
really does not really want to play the
45 and sacrifice the camera just just
took it but after 95 we see an idea of
the set up the night quickly transferred
c5 and now those three pieces are all
controlling the e4 square and this means
that white has a real hard time
really hard time to make any headway
here he played a very logical normal
moves rook to e1 III they're all this is
very very normal and I'd see if all like
it's am glad to get rid of one pair of
of minor pieces so that you can get more
and more room for for your maneuvers he
exchanged that and played rook c8
immediately getting some counter play
here Queen needed to leave the C file of
course and now night to age five and
motif that we already know and white
meets with Bishop to e5 funny move it to
make sure that there's not even more
pieces exchanged but black doesn't have
any big problem with us with that as
well Bishop retweeted and now Knight to
f6 and d5 and this means if black can
play d5 here he has completely equalized
the game in fact Nakamura now captured
on d5 we should define the Queen a form
and now after Bishop to c6 queen bee
three Bishop g5 they agree to draw with
this back-and-forth maneuver of bishop
and queen yeah White has no real option
to to avoid that the camera is the kind
of person to really look with some with
some passion to fight and should try to
continue but there really is nothing you
could try Bishop b5 this is the only
thing to avoid the media draw but in
this kind of position I mean blackest
even somewhat better coordinated to yoga
short quicker here on this false maybe
this Quincy too so this is more like
playing for Los iam than playing for
witness white white isn't in serious
trouble here I'm not saying that but
it's really a kind of a non-starter for
trying to win the game miss white so I
think it's good for fala camera too
to sometimes just recognize okay I get
nothing if I continue to play i might /
press and lose so let's just draw this
and pick some other battle so a rather
uneventful and boring draw but you need
to do those once in a while for the
tournament victory as well and not play
every game let's say with a crowbar at
the end and even lose it okay so next
game is some chronic against coyoacán an
english opening and maybe a quick word
about the move order we get Knight f6
Knight c3 e5 you might ask okay why is
black not playing a 5 on this one and
then idea 60 like like that of course
black could do that it's nowhere not a
bad move out or anything but first goal
Knight f6 has some idea after c-45 White
has the important alternative g3 when
you don't move this night so early and
this is a slight difference in in quite
a number of lines for example if black
plays something like this how are you
going to develop now of course you can
play d5 but not having played 93 means
that for example of like Bishop before
it's completely useless now and like
needs to do something else you can play
this but this means further Bishop move
is just different because the night is
already committed to c6 this means that
g3 is an important resource for white
it's not leading to something especially
great but it gives white some additional
options and by going Knight f6 first you
are sort of asking white ok what are you
doing next really want to play g3 which
would fit in this
um repertoire white can do that it's not
a bad move but here black might say all
right I don't want you five now but I
switch back to c6 for example to set of
the Slav setup or black kilowatts or
whoops not this black and also say okay
and then I go e six and d5 I don't mind
a Catalan I play that all the time so
Knight f6 is a flexible move only on
Knight c3 g6 before and something that
black usually wants to avoid the
McKenna's variation it's pretty
dangerous for black so quite often black
now goes to the c5 set up just like
kayak ended in this game so this is a
quite clever move order to avoid some
sidelines ok we get the reversed dragon
here yeah note that like needs to
retreat here it cannot keep the night on
on on d5 after move like Bishop e7
there's this technical track winning a
winning upon yeah just like that yeah or
that it doesn't matter just upon so
Knight b6 needs to retreat castles and
Bishop e7 yeah this night retreat from
d5 to be 3m this that this is forced
yeah this is actually the reason why
this setup enjoys some popularity among
white players because the reverse dragon
the tempo ok tempo is a nice nobody it's
not just the temple that's also like I'm
being committed to retreat this night um
so early so this is really a rather good
version of the dragon and reversed
colors but this still means that white
is not necessarily better black as you
can see has got very nice and
ammonius development here in this
position whites by far main move is
before this has been established as the
main line of reverse dragon for quite a
number of years but it has been played
so often people want to play something
else once in a while and chronic plays
Bishop to e3 which is a fairly normal
place for this piece in the reversed
version where black is playing the
dragon and it is very often the
intention to exchange this on c5 after
preparation like whoopsie one yeah roxy
194 Bishop c5 or on 95 even so this is
the square lc5 where whites pieces are
aiming it 95 tried to simplify yeah this
position is certainly somewhere between
equal and maybe a little something for
white but it's if it's a little
something it's very little it's simply
the the problem is blacks position
doesn't really have a substantial
weakness that you can attack maybe the
c6 c7 pawn but this is blocked by the
bishop and not easy to attack and yeah
well black is not being able to do much
it's a bit of the same for white white
has a hard time to really get something
going f6 and 92 we have this is not
really ambitious but what else took yeah
check their free and the white is still
banking on the C file of course yeah
rook c8 this is a good move protecting
the potential weakness and intending a
regrouping and maybe place the 76 and
after that it's pretty
much I'm secured on the queenside of
course it's a matter of timing you
cannot say that for all possible
positions that rise but night dat 66 is
a good maneuver in general they've got a
queen trade and denied in fact dasara
drooping wide in the media has played F
form and black took so we have a
position where white has got some good
points in the center but he also has got
three Pawn Islands while black has got
two so blacks structure is exceptionally
solid yeah tending to get some counter
play on the queenside that is attacking
here while white is attacking on b7 and
in fact we get a trade now of those two
weaknesses yeah and yeah what can you
say this is very very dry and in fact it
ended in a draw just a couple of moves
later it's very hard to to to to
recommend something great here there's
simply not much going on they shuffled
around a bit and traded for the piece
Pam it's it's certainly nothing going on
here it is very dry and there's no way
to to even set up a trap or something
it's just just very dry alright so
chrome dick with the second draw try to
get some points he still on last place
at this feels amazingly ok um next game
is mamedyarov against kawano yeah let's
have a look on the girl off place d4
like he usually does
and we get a Slav this is slightly
surprising I mean this is one of the
openings that Kara wanna is playing but
is more regularly employing a sharper
openings now usually you place them
somewhat sharp of it if you have lost
the two rather bad games with white you
probably want to be a more solid and
solid is exactly what comes to mind if
you look at this here also Quran I could
have could play e6 go to the semi slab
which can get rather sharp of course
oops else has a bit too much instead he
went g6 going for the schlitterbahn here
variation after collector the German
World Championship challenger who was
very close to becoming world champion I
am beating Glasgow in the nineteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen so that
somewhere around that was very close
this line of the slab is a bit of a
mixture between slaf and the group felt
you play this fianchetto and but you
have the Slav kind of structure nowadays
the main practitioner of this slide is
some gutter color scheme who's really
made a living out of this CM has
employed this land similar lines so
often and with the such excellent
results that it's a yes okay it's it's
still and it's still the selector
variation but it also could be called
the kamsky variation some way yeah black
has society solid in the center but has
fianchetto wood and what's the next idea
here black can play and various moves he
played here Bishop g4 which is again the
most solid line the idea is that after
this you just take it and then set up
the points all on light square so
yeah very logical and both sides have
have centralized the rooks developed
pieces and what is black set up is gone
all p all pawns on light squares he's
got the dark squared bishop so the ideal
confirmation bishop and impulse black
has no bad piece everything so nicely
centralized and it's simply an excellent
position to to just stay Black has very
little active idea here it can maneuver
around a bit and maybe of the moment is
right play be 5c 5 or b-five but all
these moves are only playable if white
does something really wrong it's usually
a kind of waiting game that like is
playing and hoping that why does somehow
overextending himself or making some
some bad judgment in progressing yeah
what is why it's plan after all actually
white only has you have two real plans
the first one is the one that
Mammadyarov is playing pushing me form
quadratically drones in the center and
the other idea this is seldom plate
simply because you on you usually don't
manage to to get it on the board is to
play c5 let's get rid of a couple of
arrows to play c5 and closing the Queen
side and play f4 so you would need to
move the Queen first and this is the big
clamp c5f for then g4 even advancing all
pawns and try to sort of suffocate black
um this can be strong but it's
not so easy to realize in fact in the
game magyar of went for this before bush
after a couple of moves before black
takes and now we see the second um
structure rising here the typical e66
structure against d4c form and this is
not um not so clear-cut the structure
because there's certain imbalance here
the imbalance is that white is got two
bishops but this bishop on b2 + b2
bishop is at the moment only the defense
of peace defending this pawn and black
can set up quite some pressure against
the point if we look at the further
course of the game just a couple of more
moves we see that black it's
intensifying as pressure on d4 and his
blocking d 5 so this advanced d45 as as
prevented if white is not managing to
play this d 45 he's almost out of ideas
what else is there you cannot really do
something on the queenside like be for a
for this is only weakening on the
kingside well g4 gives away aged for
it's also not easy so it's a bit bit
difficult for white to make any progress
of course the same applies for black
black is also not in a position to to do
any any great maneuvers but he's
exceptionally solid so i guess this was
Cavanaugh's idea to get such a very
solid position and just maybe try to to
to play for a counter-attack if possible
or if white doesn't do anything out of
the ordinary just draw it okay Sam put a
couple
more moves on the board yeah this is
interesting with Bishop a five white
managed to provoke this pawn move and
this is oops this is a weakness now but
Dwight can never really take it if you
look at this here a 5-4 exactly why it
would take now this is something to
check then in fact after the Queen e7 on
white must be cautious you shouldn't
take on c6 for example after Luke takes
rook takes Bishop takes black is clearly
better really clearly better it's at
first you think our right Alice's
opposite kind of bishops but these
bishops are indeed very air we are very
different because this Bishop is putting
pressure against f2 with Queen f6 to
come this even more and we have a
situation where two points by black
blocking three white pants so white
cannot advance any of this this means
that black is effectively playing upon
up and he's got this pressure as
mentioned against after which is more
important than the ownership so like
it's an excellent excellent shape yep um
this is what white needs to avoid you
shouldn't take the n it takes c6 so we
just dropped back Queen g7 and king of
one black cannot take d for because e
seven is always hanging at the end
something like this year loses a piece
so we have from a couple of more
maneuvers back and forth with not really
much happening but now white is ready to
play d5 and he and he plays it however
black has a pretty solid response he
took and played c5 Vince is strong
keeping this bishop out of play you have
a good diagonal with with your own
Bishop and possibilities for ninety 34
what white asses of
the deep on and he advances this he
advances it I to deform and this happen
so this point is nicely protected here
we should do five f4 and now white tries
to invade on the e-file but them it's
very difficult to make any substantial
progress as white this piece
configuration is really hard to how to
crack g7 and now we he took on deform
the problem is also on black as
threatening f5 and getting the pawn
cutting this this cover so this is why
White's fosters Shiva talk and now looky
too um yeah now white is threatening to
invade on on the seventh and make sure
that everything's traded down and after
f5 427 in fact the draw was already
agreed um after capturing yeah he aged
six um that's really and nothing wyd can
do this bone is basically lost so you
need to quickly get something rookie six
the best move threatening this capture
after King g7 rook b6 and rook takes d7
not sure which one this one maybe it is
pretty much a dead position so they
agreed to a draw not very exciting but
this line of the Slav can be a very very
good choice if you just want to stay
solid and have relatively easy to play
game you know do you you just look at
this it's very easy put everything on
light squares and await developments if
white plays before you capture and then
you put pressure on the deep bone and
make sure that you have some good reply
2d 45 I'm not saying that this is a
drawer or anything but it's a if you
really don't feel up to a very
complicated
this kind of opening is very useful to
know because you can even in not so
great shape you can put up a decent
position and fight at least 44 have a
point you know okay so we have looked at
four or five games out of course this
round had a big one with carlton against
anand the world championship match
contenders and this is the the last game
that they play before the match and this
is always um yeah some psychological
importance of course let's see what
happened cars are playing deform and we
get um limbs oh it's not not a big
surprise but island is some head um
usually played other openings against
Magnus usually cars also tried afore so
bitter for something else iam this lab
is also one of Arlen's main weapons but
okay we got the news Oh III castles and
92 yeah this is the so-called reshef ski
variation named after semi reshef ski
the American broad class Grand Master um
92 of course and tends to catch on c3
without any damage to the pawn structure
here black has more than one interesting
move he played d5 this is the main line
and Carlton played a 3 after which black
has a choice you can go to d 6 or a 7
capturing would help white at speeds up
White's development you can easily
develop and castlenet white has got two
bishops without any harm to his pawn
structure so black usually just retreats
he went to e7 in this position here in
this game there's also this move this
come is in fact interesting the bishop
is somewhat more active but it allows c4
c5
with the tempo and this is not to
everyone's taste this is also allowing
this idea but this is entirely different
okay Bishop e7 was played and now
Carlton took on d5 yeah here Anand
recaptured with the night this is in
fact a line I don't know so well I have
some knowledge about this because i have
studied this structure for the upcoming
book that i'm working on i'm working on
this BOGO and Nimue indian book and i
needed to do something against the
Rubenstein as well some some
recommendation and I had to look at this
structure which in fact i believe is
perfectly all right for black with it
takes d5 it usually leads to a very long
complicated maneuvering battle that
means it's probably equal just enough in
a mathematical sense that there's no
proven edge for white but it's also
something that will lead to a fight
because our pieces on and white can do
long-term plans that are really am
enterprising i just give one example
white for example can go or h3 in this
position which looks a bit curious at
first but it has got some idea let's say
a black play c6 then white goes gee for
this was the idea and whites ideas to
play Bishop g2 and even later after
castles play f3e for e 5 and so on so
sort of a full-scale assault just it
just developing like in slow motion
sequence it takes a while but then it's
really coming it's not like em you have
sometimes in those open positions where
everything's fireworks from the get-go
here white takes a while to build up so
II txt 5 is a good in solid move but
Allen took with the night which is not
bad it only leads to entirely different
positions yeah cousin play Bishop t2
this is a normal response
the ideas to have this Bishop takes c3
recapture which can come in handy on a
plate 97 here in Game some some time ago
against aronian Anand had played 93
Bishop takes and b6 which was also
fairly solid but now he went to 97 which
is not bad g3 and now be 6 and this I
found slightly surprising because this
is in fact known from an um yeah panel
rather old game between pon de mayo
ruslan from the Maya and chrome neck in
this game this capture was played Bishop
g2 this is exactly the point of my of
chronic gamma this is a rather
well-known game for this line because
put my of one an excellent game which
was widely published and was seen as
some really a model game from rights
perspective and it's quite strange that
Anand gets into a very similar kind of
position which is rather uninspiring in
the mansion putumayo kramnik game
chronic played Knight f6 cm castles 94
this was kramnik sir again Roxy one
Bishop d7 Quincy to rook c8 rugby 156
and Bishop before this is important
because this Bishop be formed an
excellent move really where white gets
rid of his somewhat bad bishop on d2 and
exchanges just against a very strong
bishop and dumb this in fact really
needs to some advantage
the between F 693 takes takes c6 and
Bishop do 626 we had a very one-sided
position that pony my of managed to win
an excellent fashion against chronic so
I saw I am I demonstrated the whole
whole game almost half of the game but
the thing is you need to be aware that
this is really a well-known game and the
strange thing is look what happens in
this game a nun place we should be seven
and Bishop before so cards and obviously
knew the game and went for a very
similar idea and just as some in this
earlier game of chrome legs it it's not
really nice for black let's have a look
Knight f6 was played castles and locate
here black could have tried c5 which is
interesting of course but after this
white should be somewhat better night
f-4s a key move to increase the pressure
on d5 and this Bishop is very strong on
the long diagonal exactly what white
wanted please also know that of course
taking is really bad white can we
capture and those two pawns do an
excellent job of preventing c75 and this
means that white will have pressure on
the C file and the f are very one-sided
play here black should avoid this like
the plague yeah he played rookie aid as
mentioned rookie group c 1 and now c 60
i had it's playing in a really somewhat
timid fashion it's not like i hope i'm
becky now had a slight technical hiccups
oh i was just saying that um
under some somehow playing this very
passively and but I'm not really sure
what what to recommend ok cousin
exchanged and after this year rookie one
this is getting out of this diagonal and
prepares in the long run to what to do
something with afore we see this later
and here Carlton um in the press
conference pointed out the possibility
of going 94 lat f 496 which in fact
looks like a good idea this night is
very often nicely placed on d6 this has
at least the virtue of making it very
difficult for wire to play be to before
because this invites the night right on
g4 all right to Devon we really don't
want a black night so before I said this
prevented but still look at this this
Bishop is really bad and this pawn is
weakness this is a really one sided hair
white is better and like it's just
somehow struggling here it's simply that
this maneuver with Bishop before it's
just very strong getting rid of the bad
bishop and making sure that black
special business is going away okay this
but this 90 46 was I think a possible
improvement when Alan plate is that
queen to d6 right f4 and now bishop CA
this is an idea to improve the bishop
going to f5 going to e form um but as
scars and set I understand the idea of
this move but I don't think it's really
working and yeah maybe this is this is
indeed
case look what's happened now he played
Queenie for attacking the poor and what
does like supposed to do now if black
covers this white has the very strong
move Queen before it's funny it's the
same idea again Bishop d4 and Bishop d22
before to exchange a now Queen a for
before and if you look at this just for
instance we see that white has a pretty
substantial threat EF going before b5
and getting to d5 also there's 93 e 5
this is just terrible this position like
a size is getting tortured him Bishop d7
it's not really helping this is why um
Allen played rook to c7 yeah and now I'm
this position if you don't know the game
yet you can know if you like treat assam
as an exercise what's the best move in
this position White has one move that is
exceptionally strong and make sure that
why this really am getting somewhere in
this game it's our nice but it's not
like into a direct win at this moment
you need to make some substantial
progress if you like you can stop the
video and think about this it's not a
technical solution it's a more like a
strategical idea yeah the right move and
very strong movie sf3 the ideas to go
deform it prepares c4 and c5 and this
also means that this bishop CA to move
which intended Bishop f5 is simply
useless because it would be answered
with afford white wins the peace even
with a 45 and now in this position black
ass
me helpless it is very difficult to even
stay on the board and unplayed Bishop to
e6 if you go back to make sure that
you're out of a 45 there's this coming
for example something like this or even
five is excellent for why do you see
that this lil f3 move really made sure
that all whites pieces are flowing
forwards f3 e4 e5 everything's active
now so an excellent play nobody didn't
didn't play Queen to the 83 m
frustrating move to play on a plate
Bishop to e6 and of course eform this
was the idea yet black cannot allow be
45 he took only four took and played
Queen to d7 but this in fact is met with
a direct direct answer if you like you
can again look at this for a while posts
hit hit the pause button and look for
the right knees yeah this time it's a
technical solution and this is a five
this is certainly i'm sure the first
move that many people would think of but
if you really am calculated the whole
sequence then be really strong takes
takes on g7 rook takes of course you
need to take with Luke it was attacked
and now night e six this is very strong
tags and Bishop h3 and this is already
the conflict the columns of black sir
blacks position he really has no move
now without losing substantial material
let's say rook e8 for example you take
and then the combination of the bishop
and the rook will win the size of
material black is already lost here he
played the King 2 h8 and this lost you
to e5 Knight back you should be six look
back and now white entered on the 7th
and this is the final decisive move
after which are not already resigned
it's quite simple now white will just
can push six and then just pick up the
deep one and then win just as you like
you you like has no play whatsoever this
Bishop on this evening can connection
with the porn simply freezes the whole
black position like cannot move anything
so are not resigned so a really terrible
loss I mean this psychologically
important game and I didn't see the
press conference I only read a brief
transcript of what Carlton said about
the game but I read that Donald was very
frustrated obviously after the game um
yeah certainly not knocked great to lose
like this before the match but maybe
there's some some he has some side
effects that may be cousin is um getting
too optimistic or something I don't know
just for his sake I hope that's not
happening I mean because Arnold will
certainly put up the big fights in India
pretty sure about that so what does this
mean in terms of the tournament yeah in
fact we have Nakamura still leading with
plus two together was gelfand with plus
two is playing an excellent
and now Carlton with this important win
in a metal sense not just for the
tournament Carlton is also back in the
hunt with plus one on the shout third
place with quite sure then Mammadyarov
is also on on +1 okay thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video
some games weren't so interesting but I
think the cars aren't game had some
quite interesting moments and produced a
nice visual finish here thanks for
watching I'll be back tomorrow with the
round six coverage